docteur simon phaneuf bonsoir oui
bonsoir merci
vous êtes médecin urgentologue et vous
êtes basé en maurienne c'est ça ouais en
fait j'étais j'ai fait la plus grande
partie de ma carrière sur la rive sud de
montréal mais maintenant je suis je fais
la médecine d'urgence à gaspé alors on
va beaucoup parler de la cobi de 19 ans
parce que vous semblez avoir réalisé une
belle trouvaille qui va peut être sauver
la vie de beaucoup de passion oui en
fait c'est une trouvaille qui datent pas
de la copie
c'est en fait c'est un un patient lui
même qui était atteint de fibrose
kystique qui a qui avait remarqué qu'en
allant dans un dans une fête quand ils
se tenaient près des haut parleurs et
qu'il y avait beaucoup de basse
fréquence
ça lui permettait après ça il était
capable de dégager de se dégager les
poumons plus facilement et cette
trouvaille un peu par hasard à mener des
études qui ont démontré que avec des
sons très grave une certaine fréquence
très particulière le mucus les
sécrétions des poumons devenait plus
liquide et ça s'appelait les petites
branches entre en résonance et après ça
ça permet de dégager les voies
respiratoires et c'est un produit qui a
été développée complètement au québec en
collaboration avec les universités du
québec et qui a graduellement été
utilisée principalement pour des
maladies respiratoires
quand même pas si fréquent comme la
fibrose kystique
et puis mais récemment on s'y rendre
compte qu'il y avait beaucoup plus
d'applications incluant dans certains
cas d'atteinte par la coved 19 justement
j'allais parler de la prise en charge
des cas de covec 19 notamment au québec
que j'imagine que cet appareil à vous
l'avais appelé frequenza c'est ça
oui en fait c'est un appareil qui
s'appelait pour les pointures comme si
moi j'ai pas j'ai passé pas mal
inventeur l'épaule ça je sais mais la
passion qu'il était atteint de fibrose
kystique
oui exactement et c'est un appareil qui
s'appelle le fric en turquie qui envoie
une onde sonore puis en fait c'est comme
le on est en échographie
par exemple les ondes quand on fait de
l'échographie on utilise des sons à très
haute fréquence et plus la fréquence est
élevée moins les ondes sont pénétrant
al'inverse le fruit coinceurs utilise
aussi des ondes sonores mais
complètement à l'autre bout du spectre
des ondes sonores des ondes de très
basse fréquence qui permettent de faire
essentiellement vibrer les poumons et de
permettre de dégager les sécrétions et
ça peut être utilisable pour toute
maladie respiratoire qui cause un
encombrement bronchique due à des
sécrétions ou du mucus difficiles à
déloger
vous le disiez tantôt on l'a testé sur
des patients atteints de kobe de 10,9 au
québec
est-ce qu'on a eu d'excellents résultats
par exemple je reviens de personnes
finalement est ce qu'on l'a testée vous
souhaitez tester le plus étonnamment on
a plus de données sur des patients à
l'extérieur du québec
c'est toujours difficile ça a été
utilisé dans un ensemble on parle de
patients très malades aux soins
intensifs souvent et ce qui est
intéressant de la technologie de
frequent sûr c'est que souvent par
exemple chez les patients qui sont
ventilés mécaniquement un tibet c'est
très difficile les autres technologies
de dégagement des voies respiratoires
qu'on peut appliquer sont très
difficiles à utiliser à cause de chez un
patient qui est couchée dans un lit on
peut pas mettre une veste par exemple
des choses comme ça alors le fripon
soeur va être utilisée dans des cas
comme ça où il ya un encombrement
branché chez des patients aux soins
intensifs et le avec avec tous les
autres traitements qui vont avec ça les
résultats qu'on a eus ont été bons ce
sont des rapports des patients qui ont
été faits comme je vous dis très malade
dans nos pauvres on a pas d'étude avec
des centaines de patients mais ça semble
être efficace pas remis
avec utilisation de respirateurs et
d'autres traitements le dexaméthasone et
autres et le fip answer est actuellement
utilisé dans combien d'hôpitaux au
québec
est-ce qu'à l'échelle du canada c'est un
appareil qui est connu ben c'est simple
le travail qu'on fait actuellement c'est
un appareil malheureusement qui est
assez méconnu été utilisé comme je
disais dans une dans des marchés de
niche est qui et qui est peu connu mais
dont l'usagé commence à se répandre en
fait le produit a été plus utilisé dans
des hôpitaux de pointe aux états unis
principalement en californie où la
majorité des appareils se retrouver dans
d'autres hôpitaux et en europe
souvent on est on n'est pas prophète
dans son pays par contre les filles en
fait je trouve assez curieux que cet
appareil là ne soit pas très répandue au
canada parce que valve autre communiqué
de presse j'ai vu que il a juste à 700
fait coinceurs distribuées dans le monde
oui en fait le produit commence à être
un peu plus connu est répandue au canada
d'ailleurs le gouvernement du québec
on a fait aux permis dans un 2 2 mètres
des fréquences sur 24 rick ware dans
plusieurs institutions dans le cadre des
programmes pour lakovic 19
il ya d'autres programmes similaires qui
s'en viennent mais dans les 700 il y en
a qui ont été achetés comme je disais
'mon par des hôpitaux de pointe en
californie qui sont utilisés dans des
marchés ou par exemple d'autres
technologies ne peuvent pas être
utilisés on parle par exemple en
néonatalogie des tout petits tout petit
bébé
la technologie de fruits coin sur qui
est douce et à peu près la seule qui
peut être dit mme utilisé dans ce dans
ce dans ce domaine à la même chose pour
des patients en postopératoire de
chirurgie thoracique les autres
techniques par exemple de percussion au
niveau du thorax après une chirurgie
thoracique ne peuvent pas utiliser
c'est beaucoup trop douloureux pour le
patient alors
c'est un c'est un appareil qui fait
partie qui devrait faire partie des
soins
si on veut avoir des soins complets au
niveau pulmonaire et qui recense les
indications à lui alors il ya un comité
d'experts qui va se tenir bientôt et on
parle quand même d'experts d'université
réputés comme l'université mixez-les
oxford et d'autres universités à
l'échelle du monde
de quoi sera-t-il question est ce que
vous allez essentiellement vulgariser
cet appareil là où il ya d'autres études
qui vont être menées
d'ailleurs plusieurs il ya plusieurs
volets effectivement il ya un volet
communication parce que l'appareil est
tranquillement commence à se faire
connaître mais c'est un peu triste un
dans le monde médical souvent entre
entre une découverte et son application
et que l'application de la découverte
soit répandue malheureusement on parle
de 25 à 30 ans le monde médical change
assez lentement sais c'est un peu triste
mais c'est comme ça avec wii un volet
communication il ya aussi un volet on a
dit actuellement des études en cours
avec par exemple l'hôpital
sainte-justine l'université mcgill on a
d'autres études en europe et ce comité
là va nous permettre de mieux cibler on
va cibler nos priorités parce
qu'évidemment on peut pas tout faire en
même temps de cibler nos priorités au
niveau des études et puis aussi de
développer des collaborations
alors je pense qu'on a réussi à
assembler un bon groupe
j'ai bien qu'on puisse travailler
ensemble et au niveau du cou est ce que
c'est un appareil qui est accessible
est-ce que c'est facilement distribuable
à l'échelle de la planète va en fait
quand on regarde les équipements
médicaux hospitaliers c'est un appareil
qui beaucoup moins cher par exemple
qu'un ventilateur qu un respirateur
ça s'apparente à beaucoup d'autres
appareils on parle environ avait quinze
mille 15 mille dollars plus ou moins
mais c'est un appareil aussi qui dure
une longue durée de vie donc on peut
amortir sur plusieurs plusieurs années
dans tous les cas c'est une belle
trouvaille et le monde entier en a
besoin
dans ce contexte difficile marqué par la
pandémie de covile 19
lorsque ma femme et je vous remercie
infiniment d'avoir pris le temps de nous
parler de merci ça m'a fait plaisir et
les bonnes soirées en soirées arrosées
aussi revoir